hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the feed a Riga
Grand Prix 2019 it's the finals again
it's Game two this time
Maxine washer LaGrant the white pieces
again shot her mommy yarrow shot one a
very nice game yesterday against the
groom for defense really kept MBL's
night on the room of the board and it
never saw an you know the light of day
so to say and here Maxime has an
opportunity to get back into the game if
he can win the game if you can equalize
the score then we are going into the
rapid so let's see how the game went
Maxime opens with E 4 with E 5 Knight to
f3 Knight to c6 and Bishop to c4 so the
Italian game is on the board we have
Bishop to c5 and now before well yeah
you know where I'm going with this was
not played so c3 you know the quiet game
we have Knight to f6 and now d3
defending d4 pawn with d6 by black and
now white castles with h6 now comes rook
to e1 if at some point the d4 is play d4
pawn will be protected and also
sometimes you want to play something
like Knight to lead 2 to F 1 and then
maybe to e3 or 2g 3 depending on what
black plays so here black just castle if
you try something like Knight g4 to go
after this pawn here it's really not a
problem for white white can just play
rookie to next kick away the night with
h3 and black pretty much just wasted a
move and nothing going on there and that
the rook on e2 isn't all that
problematic for white so instead mama D
our castles we have h3 now not allowing
any g4 action and a5 also a6 is a
possibility here preparing b5 but a 5 is
is a different idea with Knight B to d2
as the usual Bishop to e6 and now Bishop
to b5 avoiding this trade and now comes
Queen to b8 a very popular line being
played by a lot of top grandmasters the
idea is Queen to a6 and then the Queen
Bishop battery will be attacking the f2
pawn also probably this night is coming
to d7 you wanna push f5 maybe break open
the F file and then the rook will also
help out with
what's the attack here so nice to f1
defending the ìiî square preparing for
Queen 287 mama drf continues Queen to a7
and now we've had this position we've
analysed the game which monitor and
versus ding Liron in the Norway chess LT
box no way Chess Championship and in
that game Queen to d2 was played by
Anand and Anand was able to win the game
but here Maxime goes for Bishop to e3
but it's not a new move or anything it's
just a different line with Bishop
captures Knight captures and now Knight
to e7
this night will now come to g6 from
there it will control the f4 square very
nicely done
and also this night will at some point
come here and you want to who you want
to play a 5 either push f4 or open up
the F file so here with a four and now
Knight to g6 was played not in this game
but for example it was played in the
game kurakin versus wheeler in the world
blitz championship in 2018 where
Kerrigan was able to win a very nice
game against Sevilla and also Knight the
g6 was played in the game Magnus Carlsen
versus ding leerin in the 2017
championship showdown in the st. Louis
event but their game ended in a draw but
here we have rook a to d8 by Mahmoud yar
and now this is a new move and it is as
a rule 14 that we have a completely new
game so the idea is you want to have
more control of the d5 square once this
Knight comes to g6 d5 pawn will be
protected and you might be able to push
d5 so maxime plays Bishop to c4 regains
control of the d5 square mummy are of
traits here with bishop characters and
Knight captures and the now comes Knight
to d7 it's interesting that it's
Mammadov who prepare this line and he
came up with the new idea rook a to d8
but he now he spent 8 minutes on his
next move so very very peculiar Knight
to d7
this night can now come either to c5 to
b6 perhaps you can even push f5 if you
can do that this then black will be a
fine with d4 now by maksim and Queen to
a6 now the thread is just winning sorry
about that in the e5 pawn
the midea of defense at with Quinte sex
now first maxim has to deal with the
night here you could defend it with
Queen to b3 but he just moves it back to
e3 so night to e3 and now the question
is can you push f5 here if you can then
it's great but you can't f5 pretty much
loses the game here on the spot because
white just trades Knight captures Knight
captures captures and captures and now
you capture again captures and after
captures you get Queen d5 check and now
you're gonna lose this point after the
King moves just Knight captures on e5
you cannot recapture as the rook on the
8th is hanging so you just lost the pawn
and you don't really have all that great
of a position so all in all it would
take a miracle to save this for black
not something you can play here f5 so
rook F to e 8 by Mahmoud er of this
night when it moves the e5 pawn will be
further protected and now Queen to c2
just getting the Queen out of this D
file also the rooks are now connected
and now the route can also come into the
game with he captures on d4 by mama d RF
Knight captures on d4 and now Knight to
f6 is one way to go about it but he
prefers c6 he prepares d5 here but here
MBL pretty much forces him to get the
night over to f6 he plays Knight to f5
and now it's a very inconvenient night
and you don't really have an option of
removing it if Knight captures the other
night will just take its place the d6
pawn is under attack you're going to
have to go Knight f6 or a 5 then rook a
d1 pressured the D pawn and after d5
rookie 3 and the white starts a very
nice attack Ruby g3 is coming with some
nice pressure on the King side so here
mama Daryl says okay Knight to f6 not
committing to anything here we have rook
a to d1 Maxime brings the other look
into the game and now Knight to c8
defending this pawn here and also
pressuring the e4 pawn so here Maxime
just defends it with f3 and here it's
not all that easy to find the move for
black if you play whatever it's it's not
really doing anything so here probably
best is Queen b6 just pinning this night
here and then waiting to see what white
will
while white will play probably something
like queen 2f to get the king summer
maybe safer and wait for white to the
reaction but here
Yara felt that everything was alright
with the position that well he was doing
fine and he pushed to d5 and more often
than not if you were able to push d5 you
know create this central breakthrough
and you know live through it you will
have a very nice game so feel free to
pause the video here and try to figure
out what is wrong with blacks idea here
while I give you a couple of seconds for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent a
threatener of mates soon to happen and
for those who just want to enjoy the
show
maxime played the Queen to f2 and now
you see what the idea is
Queen to g3 followed by Queen to g7
checkmate so how do you prevent this
well one way is to go King to h7 it is
the engines will give king to h7 as the
best defensive line I'm just getting the
King away from the G file making the
room for the rook here on g8 the problem
is here he 5 is just too strong and now
you can either move the knight and then
F 4 comes which is a super strong set of
Queen g3 to follow and it will be just
very difficult to play this with black
another option is to just capture the
pawn but now you get Queen g3 the threat
is either checkmate or you lose the rook
on e5 so here you would have to give up
the exchange and then go rogue g8 but
it's not really not really something you
want to do or maybe just first Queen b6
check maybe I that a bit you pawn but
it's really not something you want to do
also okay the Queen from b6 check the
fence the rock on d8 so it is useful at
taking King H one and only now defend
mate but still you're down upon you also
down the exchange it would be like I
said it will be a miracle to save this
so even though King the king to h7 is
the strongest defense suggested by the
engine it really doesn't put up much of
a fight so here at mama door I went for
a different line he played rooked ecigs
now the rook can also perhaps be used as
a defensive piece perhaps if the knight
moves the route can come to g6 now the
knight can come over
here in the Fender g7 pawn this way so
Maxime continues Queen to g3 threatens
checkmate and now tonight's the eighth
as planned and now here at Maxime played
pawn captures on d5 it was an excellent
opportunity to grab a pawn so he took it
another way to deal with the position
was nice to d4 you attacked the rook and
after rook to g6 attacking the Queen now
Queen to h4 you attack the rook here
that's undefended and after Queen to b6
just defending the rook then e 5 and now
after you've pretty much covered
everything black doesn't really have a
good move the pawn is controlling both
of the Knights here so they can't really
enter the game the rook will be
suffering their f4 f5 is coming and it's
just a just very nice position for white
but Maxime went for a more forcing line
with a capture Sun v5c captures and
Knight captures so he grabs upon and
retains a better position with King to
f8 getting the King out of the out of
the G file and now comes Queen to h4
again Maxime threatens to win the rook
here and now look to d7 by ma media of
just getting the rock out of the way and
also the rock is now guarding the
seventh rank and here Knight to d3 by
maksim he offers the trade rooks and we
have night C to d6 also it was possible
to trade rocks here for example rock
kafirs rook a percent 97 seems to be a
nice defensive line for black if rook d7
then Knight captures an f5 Knight
captures and Queen b6 check King to h2
and now Knight to f6 seems to be the
most you know resilient defense but it's
also a very hard one to find
so after Knight d2 III we have night C
to d6 by Mahmoud er off seem you know
saying probably it's the same idea I'm
gonna capture then trade on d1 he was
probably going for the same line the
only difference is here you have well
you have a different plan nice to d4 by
Maxime here attacking the rook and now
the problem is if you go to East 7 then
you get Knight d5 and your look doesn't
really have a good square if you trade
here rook captures anyone it's just a
really terrible position to be in this
rook is now come
the e7 and it's just a really bad
position for black so here my Madeira
played rook to be five instead but now
maxime want Knight to g4 again attacking
the rook here and here we have worked to
d5 so here feel free to pause the video
and try to find the best move for maxime
beaugeois grab in this position well I
have another sip of my water for those
of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
creator of monster Knights and for those
who just want to enjoy the show tonight
the e5 is the move and it was in this
position on move 32 that Sharma media
resigned the game and Maxine Varsha
holograph is back in the game so to say
we are going into the rapids as the
classical time format is now drawn now
both players won one game the problem
here now for black is that you don't
have a good square for the rook you
can't go here the Queen is still
attacking that square if you go to East
7 then you get Knight g6 check just open
up a discovery after the knight is
captured you will capture here King
moves Queen d5 check picks up the other
hook as well and black just falls apart
on the other hand after Knight to the e5
if you go rook to c7 it's no better just
Queen d8 and what do you play now
there's really not not a good move to
play here you will simply move this
night and then well threaten rook
captures here so King to g8 is possible
but then again just Knight g4 and you
don't have you don't have a reply to
this you will simply start losing
material so your only option here is to
capture the night but you are already
down upon and now you're going to be
down the exchange and mommy there really
doesn't feel like playing out this
position so like I said after 95 he
decided to resign the game and now it is
a 1-1 victory for each of them and we
are going into the rap it's like I
mentioned oh yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it very nice comeback
by Maxime and if you look at mama door
off screen here on a6 it really reminds
us of MBL's knight in the groom fold in
the previous game where it didn't leave
the a file for the entire
and you know this Queen pretty much
suffered a similar fate at this game
so very nice comeback and yeah I would
like to thank Sauron or Astana which
Paul Woodhull and Douglas bro hard
Douglas also says IV duck says happy
anniversary he's your checkmate
obviously a very nice way way to you
know wish someone a happy anniversary so
there's that as usual you can check two
of my previous videos your think all for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the finals
here continuing the capablanca saga and
checking up on your suggestions as used
usual if you haven't do update your
other matters just [ __ ] it has now been
fully released you are able to comment
and rate the app so feel free to do that
as well thank you I will see soon and
have an excellent rest of your day